[Music]
quentin joins us in san antonio texas
quentin welcome to the ramsay show
hey thank you for having me today yeah
how can i help
so i'm 21 years old um he's got a small
family i'm about to get married i've got
a two-year-old son well he's about to
see next week
and i don't want to rent the rest of my
life um
i'm just trying to figure out what steps
do i need to take this safe up and and
eventually buy a house in the next two
to three years
okay what's your household income
right now for us we
are probably
lower 50s
altogether um i am about to start uh i'm
looking into being a police officer um
over in san antonio so i know my income
would would definitely jump up from that
um but yeah right now about lower to mid
50s okay well it's a simple math
equation and we've got a great mortgage
calculator over at ramseysolutions.com
you click on free tools there and jump
on there but what it comes down to is
not being house poor so i know you don't
want to rent forever but i also don't
want you to be house poor and have this
mortgage payment taken over your life as
you try to start off this marriage with
a two-year-old and so what i would do if
i were you is start looking at what
houses cost in the area
and then set a goal and say all right
the house is 300 000
and if we're going to have this mortgage
payment be under 25 of our take-home pay
on a 15-year fixed-rate mortgage here's
how much we would need to save for the
down payment
and so then you know your down payment
goal now we have a very tactical goal we
want to save 60 000 in three years
that's 20 grand a year how are we going
to do that well it might mean taking on
a side job it might mean
getting a new job and getting some extra
income coming in and so you guys need to
decide what that looks like for you but
it might also mean you need to adjust
your expectations and your time horizon
and go all right the houses are that we
want is 350 000. are we willing to not
get that house right now and get a 200
000 condo
or are we okay waiting five years and
getting that house so that it's uh
inside of those parameters does that
make sense
yeah that makes a lot of sense yeah so
i'm rooting for you man congrats on the
marriage and everything you've got going
on and i know man renting
you're just like man i'm throwing money
away now you're not you're buying time
you're buying patience that's what it
comes down to and uh if you want to
listen to one of the episodes and the
fine print we did on this is now the
worst time to buy a house we dig into
the housing gold rush and everything
going on with that crisis and i think
it's going to give you a lot of hope uh
rachel cruz will walk you through the
green lights as to when you're ready to
buy a house we talked to brian biffini
real estate industry analyst we talked
to a guy who foreclosed back in 2008
because he jumped in because he was like
you i don't want to waste money on rent
oh